one moment please stand by
stuart are we ready to go now
uh one moment
okay
having a small difficulty with the
linkedin
tracy nice to meet you
looking forward to this nice to see
everyone
see you too
much better
and the live stream has begun
okay
all right
all right good morning good evening
everyone here welcome to the first umass
simply learn online convocation pgp 2021
i am paris i am currently working as
senior program manager at simply learn
taking care of
learners experience for digital business
and digital operations courses
i have around seven years experience in
strategy and operations across startups
corporates and education space
i you know i graduated from the
university of oxford with an mba just
two years back
and i remembered how exciting and how
fun the convocation was
you know that's that's where i got my
display picture for my social media
accounts
and i'm so excited you know today to be
here on the other side of convocation as
a host
today it's all about appreciating and
celebrating your success
um
now thinking of the journey that you all
have been through you know i know it
requires a lot of consistent effort and
a lot of prioritization of learning over
other areas of life especially in these
tough difficult pandemic times it's so
good to see this positivity that all of
you have prioritized learning you know
over other
difficult
you know in such a difficult
circumstance
i've been through courses uh like this
in the past
i know it requires you know consistent
efforts and a high degree of persistence
to successfully finish these courses
going through hundreds of hours of
learning 20 plus projects and
assessments and finally you've
implemented what you learned throughout
finally in the capstone projects super
impressive
this is an amazing accomplishment folks
you're all champions all of your
super achievers
well uh this is
now the time
for our guest speakers to
address the gathering
first i would like to take this
opportunity to introduce mark our chief
marketing officer at simply learn
his expertise lies at the intersection
of marketing and strategic planning
he brings a delicate balance
at aligning the needs of the users and
business
he has led several
early and growth stage startups and has
generated more than 1.5 billion dollars
in exit value an mba from stanford
university
he focuses on data and soft skills to
build high functioning teams
mark i request you to share a few
inspiring
words with our achievers today over to
you
thank you paris um welcome everyone uh
this is this is truly the my
favorite part of my job
you know this is the culmination of all
that we do internally and simply learn
to try to put together courses that are
relevant and can you know help people
achieve their career and life's goals
and to to be here
amongst you all who have just gone
through
you know which is
essentially sort of an epic journey
it's very humbling it's very inspiring
um you know your work ethic and ethic
and commitment over these last
eight nine ten twelve months
uh you know and the dedication that you
put into this program your your specific
program
is uh truly inspiring
and it's also inspiring to us
knowing that you know
a significant portion of your free time
has probably been spent uh advancing
this program and you've entrusted that
to simply learn and to university of
massachusetts so we're humbled to have
been
perhaps a larger part of your life that
at times you wished um but i i think now
having reached this moment hopefully you
uh feel was all worth the effort um so
each of you you know you're walking away
with a new set of skills
and the certifications uh to verify your
proficiency
and we spent a lot of time you know in
these programs trying to
really put together the skill sets that
are most demanding global corporations
and startups and the public sector and
more
um so i think you are you're very well
equipped from uh you know a skills and
um
you know specific learning's perspective
but
i actually think equally important to a
prospective
manager or employer
is the fact that you've demonstrated
that you are
wholly committed to your career
and to lifelong learning and betterment
and that mindset
won't just make you successful it will
drive the success of your company and
your organization and those people that
are sitting across the table from you
now or in the future
are going to
know that this is somebody who's really
engaged isn't doesn't just know the
skills but is truly
committed to continuing to learn and
better themselves and increase those
skills
you also walk away with another i think
incredibly valuable asset which is each
other
this is a very accomplished group we
could forward the slide here we have a
couple of slides
on the demographics of the group
um
but as you can see here over two-thirds
of you
um have more than eight years of
experience
with the industry you could see there's
a lot of unknown in the industry but you
you you cross a number of different
industries
and clearly came to these programs
already
with a great deal of career
accomplishment
and so please now reach out to each
other and stay in touch with each other
because your cohort is another
really valuable career asset
um you have a you know an amazing group
of people to continue to get to know and
to learn from
in addition uh you know please also stay
in touch with us
uh we're here you know to champion your
ongoing career success
um and to support you as best we can so
you know as they say i think now the the
fun begins
um
you know i first hope that uh sharing
this accomplishment with your friends
and family is is where where it all
starts and then you really take this to
your prospective organizations and
workplaces and you know really have an
impact on the world
so uh and i'm sure you will this is a
very accomplished and
you know really inspiring group of
people so i'm going to leave you with
two quotes
just to think about as you begin this
next phase of your journey
one is uh from number two he's only the
second richest man in the world jeff
bezos
quoting jeff here what we need to do is
always lean into the future
when the world changes around you
and when it changes against you
what used to be a tailwind is now a
headwind
what you have to do is lean into that
and figure out what to do
because complaining is isn't a strategy
and obviously just based on who you are
and what you've just done over the last
many months
you are not the complainer group of
people you're the people who are going
to lean in
second quote is from
peter drecker is the name i hope all of
you know or at least google one of the
greatest business minds of the 20th
century
and it's very simple
the best way to predict the future is to
create it
and i think that's what you all in the
midst of doing
so again uh congratulations for all
you've accomplished thank you for
allowing us to be part of the journey
and we're very excited for you to to uh
see what you do next
so all the best
thank you
thank you mark uh for your kind words
and thank you for sharing these insights
with the learners
up next
we have our guest of honor
professor tracy uh
she's associate dean and professor of
information systems at umass she has
reached 30 plus years of experience
across
cooperates in top u.s universities in ma
and phd in information systems from
virginia tech
her research interests include human
computer interaction with theory driven
experimental design decision making and
decision support systems user evaluation
and acceptance of information systems
trust in information systems uh she's
one you know
it's too short a time to just talk about
the accolades and awards that she's won
some of them include uh eisenberg
outstanding research award you must
hammer 2012 eisenberg research
excellence award uh 2011 and
transactions of on human computer
interaction best paper of
2011.
her teaching interests include business
intelligence and analytics
business processes and enterprise
systems data price
database management and research
methods
she administers four master's degree
programs three pgp programs at eisenberg
school of management and and
the good thing is all pgp graduates they
have a pathway to
isenberg online mba programs
professor tracy it's a real pleasure to
have you here
uh
i now request you to you know share a
few insights
and some
interesting thoughts with our learners
today
over to you professor tracy
great
thank you so much paris for having me
here today it is really my great
pleasure to be here
um at this commencement ceremony
uh and to recognize the accomplishments
of this group of learners who are
completing postgraduate programs in
project management lean six sigma and
agile through the partnership between
simply learn and umass amherst
so for for you graduates for you your
learners you've taken a very significant
step beyond your undergraduate degree
and for some of you beyond a graduate
degree even to invest in yourselves and
embark on a graduate level program in a
highly marketable and skilled knowledge
area
many of you have pursued this learning
opportunity while also working full-time
and juggling all the challenges and the
joys that accompany careers families
partners and children and
on top of that during a pandemic
for some of you it was your first time
learning in an online environment and
taking advantage of the different modes
of delivery provided with these pgps
whether that meant recorded lectures
live online sessions with master
instructors or a range of online
resources with problems tests and real
world projects
so i want to start off today by saying
you know really what an outstanding
effort i applaud you and i celebrate
your success as a program completer and
again it's my great pleasure to be with
you today
i thought i would share a little bit
about the umass amherst mission
statement and our strategic plan
the university of massachusetts amherst
was founded in 1863
as a land-grant university dedicated to
educating its citizens generating new
knowledge and applying discoveries to
the betterment of society
through the generations the original
agricultural and mechanical focus
broadened into nearly every aspect of
modern life and into a larger obligation
to the diverse and geographically
dispersed communities that we serve
today
the university's mission is to provide
affordable
and accessible education of high quality
and to conduct programs of research and
public service that advance knowledge
and improve the lives of the people of
the commonwealth the nation and the
world
today our strategic plan launched by
chancellor subbaswamy
builds on the foundation of the
university's mission
and the special obligations of our
flagship campus
we seek to create a positive impact on
our society through education and
advancing knowledge
as the flagship public university in
massachusetts a stronghold of
educational offerings worldwide we
cherish
and add to a long tradition of
intellectual and educational leadership
our institution is rooted in the idea
that any qualified individual regardless
of wealth or social status
should have access to higher quality
higher education
we draw from and support diverse
experiences and perspectives as an
essential strength of this learning
community and except for ourselves and
instill in our students an ongoing
commitment to create a better and more
just world
the eisenberg school of management in
particular is an internationally ranked
business school
the financial times has ranked the
online mba program that we offer as
third in the world
u.s news ranks our online and part-time
mba program is 26 out of 295 programs
fortune magazine ranks our online mba
program is ninth and whatever the
ranking eisenberg is near the top
the same master instructors who taught
in your postgraduate program teach in
our highly ranked graduate degree
programs
you've learned from them you've
experienced them you're part of our
community
the umass postgraduate programs hold
great value beyond the skills and the
knowledge that you have obtained
and we're beyond grateful to have worked
with simply learn to offer
the program that you have completed the
programs that you have completed
so whether you are seeking a change in
career or an advancement within your
current employer your postgraduate
program provides you with an in-depth
knowledge and relevant skills that
you'll be able to put to use immediately
and you're now an alum of umass amherst
and a recipient of all alumni benefits
a member of the umass amherst community
and network
you receive discounts on educational
products including the eisenberg
graduate programs
as next steps now that you've completed
this journey
we ask that you consider what you can
accomplish next and think about your
graduate education
you've demonstrated great success in
your online graduate pgp
and you're ready to put the knowledge
and skills that you've earned to good
use and continue to learn
so complete those industry
certifications that are associated with
your pgp
for those in project management your
next steps should be the certified
associate in project management
or the pmi agile certified practitioner
there's a long list of certifications
and accomplishments
that align with your pgp's and that's
what makes them so valuable
you can also consider pursuing a
graduate degree
add an additional credential to your
name consider the eisenberg graduate
programs or other programs but you're
really set up with the pathway into our
online mba program
your pgp can transfer in as a focus area
in project management lean six sigma or
agile and you'll be given nine credits
or three graduate business courses
toward our online mba program
you've already accomplished so much
take that next step whether it's a
certification an industry or another or
a graduate degree
get started you're ready for it
you've taken that step and now keep the
momentum going
so again i offer my warm and hearty
congratulations and my sincere wish for
the happiness and success for you now
and in the future
be bold as they say be courageous and be
your best as you move forward with the
knowledge you've accomplished and the
knowledge that you have still to gain
congratulations
well thank you tracy uh for sharing
these insights and such like nice and
kind words with our learners uh thank
you so much uh next we have ram
a very illustrious alum of umass
he's currently chairman of board of
directors at aryaka networks and jovio
inc he also serves as an independent
director on the board of directors of a
number of early and growth stage
companies like postman inc
hacker think simply learn welkin
health nimbela and niyamo previously he
served as
director on the boards of various
startups and public companies including
progress software
s1 corporation platforms computing
yearly latitude systems and many more
he's a ms he's done his ms computer
engineering from university from umass
and his bs in electronics engineering
from bitsvillani india
he's member of mensa and he holds
several patents in the us
he was awarded this smithsonian computer
world search for the heroes award for
the year 2000 for his work on a
healthcare
integration platform
as a senior executive and independent
board member ram has been part of teams
that have created market capitalization
of over 20 billion
dollars he's been part of three ipos and
nine acquisitions
uh deeply involved with the venture
capital ecosystem in silicon valley and
serves as strategic advisor to altis
ventures
previously served as strategic advisor
and managing director to nexus venture
partners and strategic advisor to kalari
capital uh
i'm so glad that mark is uh here with us
marketing would be great if you share a
few insights and some inspiring words
with our achievers today
sure hi can everybody hear me okay
yes mark
oh that's wrong
yeah
i only wish i had that vida thank you so
much paris i'm gonna i owe paris a
little extra thank you
well this is my first
convocation
so
i don't know what to say but what i
thought i'll do is just
share my uh my story of
a convocation at umass that i was
supposed to have but never did
and uh
and that'll take me back to around 97
and
a little less known fact about umass
that most of you may not know
umass was a pioneer in online education
so in 97 i was doing my first startup
a company called webmd some of you might
have
gone to webmd when you're feeling down
with health issues and
figure out that you have cancer
very quickly if you go to the website
and you don't but that's what the
website will take you through
uh it was a great uh
company we had an ipo in 99
a wonderful outcome
back in the day
so at that time i was looking to uh
just like you guys have done
to get further education uh
in an online fashion
i
didn't have the luxury of giving up my
my startup
and go to school full time
and as looked around the country united
states
i found that umass was offering this
excellent and more than excellent you
know just the same
course
in computer science
that they were offering on campus
and they were also offering uh online
and so i got accepted uh thank you to
school for accepting me for that program
and
at that time i don't know how many of
you know what a video cassette is
but at that time the online program that
umass used to have
was that the faculty at the umass campus
would teach the students there
and then they would record it at the
same time and they would send those
recorded video cassettes in mail
to people like me who were doing a
remote learning or online program uh at
that time
and uh you know we would watch the
cassettes and you do the homework and we
would do the exams
and so that's how i got my masters and
ems was the first i think the
the if not the first the very very few
uh that started and understood
the value of offering education
that is not confined within the four
walls
of a campus and i spent some time with
dr swami who is chancellor of umass
and he talks about his borderless
campus which means that whether you are
in the campus or you're away from the
campus
the quality of education has to be the
same
and that's my that was my experience
with umass that that i got such high
quality
learning uh getting my master's degree
and then i was supposed to go for
convocation in 99
when i finished my class
and it so happened that that was the
time
uh we were going ipl so
that very day actually so so we ended up
going public and i unfortunately i
booked my ticket i was gonna go to the
campus receive my diploma
but i couldn't i couldn't do it because
we were ringing the bell that day on the
nasdaq exchange
uh so i miss my convocation and i'm so
happy that this is giving me an
opportunity to be part
of a convocation i kind of feel
vicariously through you all i'm also
receiving my diploma today dr tracy is
here maybe she'll also bless me
with
the degree that i received back in 99
from from umass
uh a couple of thoughts for you to
consider as you've done this incredible
work
is
one
i'm still studying
so we are all we need to all become
lifelong learner currently i'm
i'm signed up
in an online program to get a
degree in
psychology and counseling because it's
an interesting area for me
so so i'm doing that and that just to
tell you that even when i'm now 60 year
old
and have been very fortunate in my
career
i'm still going back to school still
learning still
building a network of people
so as you look ahead in your career
a constant learning of forever learning
is the new norm gone are the days when
you can go to college or school and get
a degree and the rest of your life
you're good that time is gone now you're
learning all the time the second thing i
want to leave you with is that when i'm
interviewing people for various jobs
whether they're ceos or cross or cmos or
what have you
it
matters to me when i'm talking to them
as to how they got their education
and are they
learning all the time
and when somebody says to me you know
they got their
undergrad degree or master's degree
or
certifications
while they're working
that leaves me with an impression that
this person
is is a different kind of a person this
person is a person who is always
learning
and while they're working they are
dedicated and motivated
to make the time to find the time find
that extra
ounce of energy
every day
to go back to learn to do quizzes to do
tests
the citizens it puts you all
in a special category of people
who have chosen to be learning all the
time
and i want to say to you that is not
lost on people like me
when we are interviewing people and we
come across people who are learning at
that moment
or are learning uh online
it tells us that you guys are
far more motivated far more dedicated
than regular people so it creates a
differentiation in addition to the
diploma of course that you get but it
creates differentiation in my mind
from the hiring side
when people are doing uh education as
part of the journey versus
i study it and then i'm working mindset
the other thing i want to leave you with
is that
the power of networking i also look back
at my journey
a lot of goodness has come to me because
we we created a network of people who
were my advisors who were my guides
who were my friends who were my
colleagues
so as mark mentioned as
tracy mentioned as you are
starting your next chapter
the cohort of people that you studied
with i'll encourage you guys to maintain
close ties relationships
with your instructors in the program and
also
the the fellow colleagues
these relationships
are very useful or very powerful in in
in building your career
and the last thought i want to leave you
with is that to close it all is that
at this point in time in the world
what stands
us apart
as people
and and i believe what stands us apart
sort of repeating what
marx said
is are we constantly
leaning in
to the changes that are going around
whether it is macro factor
economic factors
technology changes
we are leaning the people who are
leaning in are the winners
and the people who are leading out
are
most likely not gonna survive or not
gonna make it
and all of you have proven to yourself
and to the world
that you're the leaning in
people so god bless congratulations
for being a different kind of people
people who were leaned in
for the careers and growth
and i do wish you a
learner learning forever don't think of
this as
as your last stop in learning think of
this as
your first
first step in learning you have tasted
how
you can learn online you don't have to
go to a physical college
to continue to learn more
i encourage you
i challenge you
to keep learning
thank you so
much many thanks ramp
and
such valuable insights on lifelong
learning and building strong
relationships with our fellows that can
you know take us places thank gram for
such valuable uh live
lessons
um
alright let's uh move on to the next
phase of our journey now this is the
time to reflect on our journey
uh so was it easy was it too difficult
uh
how was the experience on a scale of one
to five how difficult do you think you
know the journey was let's do a quick
poll and see
where we are
here we have 15 seconds to go
all right let's see where we are
oh great i think majority lies in three
and four we can see more than 60 percent
feel that it was not too difficult and
not too easy and i think that's how it
should be if if the course is too easy
then you know it's it's no challenge we
don't push ourselves and if it's too
difficult we get like too anxious so
it's good to see that most of you found
it to be on the level of three or four
where
we i can clearly see that all of you
have pushed yourself to be out of your
comfort zone and you've all grown as a
part of this journey so so good to
uh see these numbers
um
well let's move uh now to
you know let's move to the most exciting
part of this event you know let's hear
from some of your
peers about
their journeys
let's call
muhammad bashi to share his experience
with us
can we have uh mohammed bashir here
hi paris
hey hi
yeah hi good morning and uh good evening
to everybody so thank you for giving me
this opportunity
so as mr ron rightly said so learning is
a continuous process and it gives us
satisfaction and more knowledge so when
i took the course initially i would like
to learn only the project management and
to clear my pmp exam that's the main
agenda for taking the course
but then i decided to check what was
there in other courses as well so it
completely pulled me in
so
i feel really accomplished and had a
satisfaction of learning more than just
pmb especially when it comes to scrum
master
and digital transformation where i have
gained more knowledge and concepts of
project management along with the soft
skills
and trending technologies
so the good thing in simply land what i
personally feel advantage from this
particular forehead is it's a kind of
way there is nothing as you said it's
nothing is easy to easy at the beginning
but here i can
say my personal uh advantage in taking
the course so at first the concepts are
explained in a micro level by the live
classes or variable experts with real
time examples in different domains so by
that way we can able to understand the
concepts at the beginning then we can
have our own
self-learning videos at our own pace of
time and convenience then we can have a
better understanding so these two
we can have
we can able to
get information about the concepts two
times one from the live as well as from
the self learning videos but thirdly we
can able to check ourselves with the
knowledge
and assessment at each and every end of
each and every chapter so that helps us
to
assess our progress and our current
level of planning so that is a third
thing finally the better part is which i
feel completely impressed is the project
capstone and other mini projects which
gives us complete confidence allowing us
to work on real-time projects using
different tools such as jira ms project
whatever it is relevant to the scrambled
pm which i feel really good so these
four levels of
packed the course so this allows us to
learn more
than just learning so the course content
is really good and the trainers are very
well experienced they are providing very
easy and simple examples real time
examples and they are explaining
important content as well so
from the real uh scenarios using some
other links and the resources also it's
very good so this is a long slow
steady journey which is the right way
for any learner to learn a concept so
the good thing is that
the collaboration with umass university
which adds more value to my resume so
already
notified my company my family and
friends and i feel
recognized
it's a good thing so simply
in collaboration with you much
is a kind of
advantage i can say so more than that i
received a good support from the support
team wherever i raise queries they are
attending it and resolving in a timely
way so this is the better thing about
the course so
i would suggest uh others also to go
with simply land so it's very easy it's
very compact and there are a lot of
concepts being explained and from the
beginner to the professional level of
learning how to go with simplyland and i
like to
recommend this course for other people
as well and i i will definitely continue
in other way as well thank you so much
uh
mr paris
thank you mohammed bashir for sharing
your experience and sharing your stories
with with us today
let's have share her experience now
can someone uh
get a car
hello everyone
good morning
feel free to switch on your video
okay sure um
hello everyone uh good morning and good
evening
so uh
this was a wonderful uh six
month journey
with experienced uh and learned mentors
and professionals
and i believe
it was a great opportunity
to connect with everyone and uh i mean
this coursework is actually very well
struck
pictured and organized
and i mean i learned so much from this
virtual platform
an opportunity as a beginner in our
project management
thank you so much
simply learn umass all the mentors and
my fellow learners and
sadhanan shirky share his experience
hello good evening and uh good morning
to everyone i am wing commander
i have
recently completed my term in the indian
air force
i served in the logistics branch
i first of all congratulate all my
ghostbusters in the course and uh
especially this is a very special course
for me
uh as i started learning with simplyland
uh it was march 2020 basically to enable
my transition from the military into the
corporate world
i loved the method of sending the
preparatory courses in advance before
starting the main courses
i was asked in search of a kind of a
learning platform which would prepare me
for
achieving smooth transition from the air
force and also would
enable the corporate world to value my
experiences and abilities
i had sufficient administrative and
managerial experience
in the service and also the right
mindset what i actually was requiring
was the right skills and right
certifications
the entire course has helped me gain
life skills understand the corporate
life various roles the terms
challenges and certifications
i am highly thankful to umass amherst
and
simply then for the fabulous course
design creating the valuable content
which is available for the lifetime
and this also gets updated regularly
so i shall also have the updated
contents
and
i also appreciate the
amazing delivery style
through the live lectures self-learning
videos
very
very nicely prepared mobile application
and i'm very happy with the entire
package because it was covering so many
subjects
i am specially thankful to my
instructors from umass amherst faculty
mr
jeffrey m clark for the live classes
that he has conducted also mr sandeep
soche mr dee sweetheart
miss anita
for conducting live classes project
mentoring sessions brainstorming
sessions
i convey my sincere thanks and regards
to each and everyone in the team
lots of good luck thank you so much
yeah
thank you sadarand and it's a unique
career transition now so good to hear
about your experience here uh
well thank you all for sharing your
experience with us i'm really energized
after listening to your stories uh now
let's see how much did these stories uh
you know resonate with your own story
let's do another quick poll to see you
know if these stories resonate with you
with your own story
we have 20 seconds 24 seconds left
three
two
one
all right let's see the results
oh wow
95 percent of people are able to relate
to these stories that's
that's really great uh if you have your
own unique stories please do share with
us through the chat window we would love
to hear from you
uh well now let's come to the agenda
which is you know celebration
uh all of you have made it you know the
time has
come now to call
out all the achievers i would like to
congratulate each one of you for this
massive achievement
so let's start the celebration across
all these three programs we'll start
with our
project management program
congratulations shashank
very very well done sharana
congratulations muhammad congratulations
satyr narayana congratulations latoya
well done kavita
great work jivita congratulations
archana
congratulations margareta
congratulations alisha
very very well done so we have more
people who have graduated from our
project management program
uh congratulations laika
congratulations rizwi
good work
uh congratulations
congratulations sadanand very very well
done uh congratulations vignesh
uh well done jonathan congratulations
roger congratulations uh shikha
congratulations prieta congratulations
tiffany
mike
sahar
congratulations vijaya
weldon surekha
congratulations
congratulations troy
congratulations joseph
amazing work jeremy congratulations nada
congratulations rebecca congratulations
anka
congratulations alison
congratulations sparrows
congratulations very
good work roger
congratulations aman congratulations
deepak
congratulations
uh weldon sajeev
congratulations kuan
uh weldon chandan congratulations
weldon srimani congratulations mohammed
congratulations charlene
weldon paulo
congratulations damian weldon
good work aparna
very good
gotham
congratulations ramesh
good work ankur congratulations ram
congratulations dave prasad
congratulations andrew allah
congratulations avinash i'm so excited
to be here today congratulations public
navaran
congratulations daniel
congratulations saltomash
now we move to our second program which
is our pg lean six sigma so well and
achievers
uh
congratulations toby congratulations jay
uh congratulations joseph
congratulations nehemiah
congratulations welinder congratulations
era
congratulations mansi
congratulations
dojo
uh weldon riyaz
uh congratulations nikhil
congratulations vipin
uh congratulations ada
uh prashanth well done congratulations
ganesh
uh congratulations edwin congratulations
sarah
weldon
imart
congratulations rosemarie
congratulations jan
uh
weldon oluzuola congratulations donald
congratulations elizabeth
congratulations wayne
weldon patrick
congratulations jennifer
uh congratulations mary
congratulations mubashir
congratulations oh mom congratulations
gustavo
weldon eddie boomi congratulations
joseph
this is amazing work
we have
seven more people from lean six sigma uh
congratulations james
uh congratulations ashweed
congratulations saluna
belden randy
weldin poona
weldon lydia ah congratulations emma
now we move to our agile program uh
congratulations vizivi
congratulations naga
congratulations kashish
welding anita
weldon
milani
very very well known all of you
so we have some folks who have performed
extraordinarily well you know and to
recognize these
extraordinary performers we have two
kinds of awards so one is scholars award
the other one is speed runners award
scholars award is given to people who
have done exceptionally well on the
assessments and projects
uh so let's
let's just celebrate
this huge success you know with
with all of you
let's announce the winners the scholars
uh for our project management program uh
we have
we have jivita so very very well done
jivita congratulations this is like
really amazing and inspiring uh
congratulations parker
congratulations joseph
very very well done uh congratulations
wayne
uh
congratulations jennifer
so good to
see all of you performing like really
well
uh
let's move on
so for our agile program all of you have
performed like really well so we have
speedrunner awards uh for for agile
folks
uh let's let's announce speedrunner uh
awards for all categories let's let's
start with our project management uh
speedrunners and speed runners are the
award winners who have done the who have
completed the program the fastest
uh so you look super speedy
congratulations uh chivita very very
well done
uh once again jivita congratulations for
winning both
awards both scholars award and
speedrunners award like this is
really inspiring uh very very well done
a huge round of applause for you
um
congratulations muhammad
congratulations sri mani very well done
for our lean six sigma we have mubashir
congratulations mubashir congratulations
patrick
very very well done
so good to see you
uh let's move to our agile category we
have mulat here with us who's the speed
runner
congratulations mulat
congratulations olufsa
very very very well done
uh
now i would like jeevitha who is our
award winner you know for both
both categories both speedrunner and
scholar category to to share experience
with all of us so if we can have jivita
share an experience that will be great
jivita we can't hear you can you unmute
yourself
i did are you able to hear fine we can
see you we can hear you yes
cool thank you very much um very excited
to be here
um
thank you very much for the opportunity
it is so great um to hear from our
accomplished um
guest of honor and what mr gupta said um
actually resonates with me um
he mentioned learners are a different
kind of people so this inspires me to
never stop learning at any stage thank
you sir for that
i'm truly honored to share my journey
and
learning experiences but simply learn
and uh umass for the post graduate
program in project management so when i
look back um actually my journey would
simply learn um started back in 2014
and i should say
simply learn has helped me quench my
thirst to learn
at every stage of my career and help me
cope with the changing technologies
initially i was a little undecided about
speaking today for a while um especially
considering all the challenges with work
with uh work from home and all of those
stuff and then i thought everything is
always changing and that shouldn't stop
me from saying what i want to
so when i signed up for this course to
be candid i was a little unsure if i
would make it given the challenges
involved um with covert switching
contacts between work and family and of
course the covert times we are all in um
you guys know like what we're going
through so obviously including
commitment to take few hours
out on all the weekends needed to
complete this course it was
a little bit of a cat on the wall kind
of decision but after few weeks of
starting this program i was actually
fascinated with the knowledge
of my trainers and batch mates in the
virtual classes it was really the people
i feel i met have made this place what
it is to me
and uh they've really made me want to
succeed to be very honest about that
and i have a few people to thank first
of all i'd like to thank my uh family
for their never ending support um i
really wouldn't be here without them and
for that i'm truly grateful i also want
to thank um my trainers um some of my
trainers
i um
was very inspirational to hear from it
was very inspirational to hear from
fariha salman
for the pmp course gaurav
for
agile scrum master course and um
vikas aguero for a six sigma green belt
course
they have been uh constance uh
consistently amazing throughout my
learning time here and since the
beginning they've been very insightful
sharing examples from various industrial
um
experiences um and so much more
finally i'd like to
thank my co-learners for being such an
inspiration and sharing their real-time
experiences in the class uh to help
connect concepts better if any of my
batch mates are here
i do remember some of the names uh pagli
naman dania nada hasan
hasan rebecca thank you very much guys
i've learned a bunch from you all you
all are a champion
out of all this um program has actually
thought one thing um it's not selfish to
believe in yourself
and that is the lesson that i'll
remember so thank you again if i had to
share one take away for the new students
um it would be this
learning takes time and
obviously like dedication
so plan to spend two to three extra
hours each week reading through forums
and preparing for the class and finally
it doesn't matter what mistakes you make
today because you can still try again
tomorrow with that note cheers everyone
and thank you
hey that's congratulations once again
and so good to hear
from you and hear your stories uh
thanks once again and congratulations
once again to everyone here
so now i would like to introduce you all
to the team behind the scenes working
relentlessly
to make sure that you have the best
learning experience
the idea behind this is to put a face to
the names that you've heard and
interacted with in the past one year
uh
let's let's move on uh first i would
like to introduce our trainers we would
like to take this opportunity to you
know thank our faculty on your behalf
to for constantly supporting us
throughout the program
uh
and now i would now you know like
a few of our trainers to
share their journey with us
uh
so sridhar if you
it would be great if you share your
journey with all of us today
yeah sure can you all hear me yes either
we can hear it clearly
yeah so
thank you so much uh
it's lovely being here part of this
first convocation of umass amherst so my
journey with uh simply learn started way
back in
2011
and uh
i've never looked at another institute
to be frank because i'm so
uh excited to be part of this journey
and you know it started with classroom
delivery lectures and now today
i just moved on to online and this post
graduate program in particular is of
great interest to me because
you know the kind of bundling that it
offers the different courses
the
and the content especially
is very very
uh contemporary and i really appreciate
the hard work that goes into maintaining
the content and you know presenting it
the right way so i think kudos to simply
learn team for that and the second
aspect of
the entire
layout of the learning for the learners
from simply learn is the way it is
structured
the convenience the sheer convenience
the flexibility because all are working
professionals and the kind of
flexibility that one gets
through all these courses
with the self-learning videos and of
course the lectures and then the
recordings available later so that we
can always come back that is really
the industry best i should say and of
course not to forget the community of
practice which is very very critical and
you know i'm able to connect with so
many
learners beyond the classes also during
and beyond the classes
so you know as a learner we have so many
doubts so many things which come up
later not during the lecture per se so
when we go through the recording
suddenly you say hey i think i should
need a little more elaboration on this
and so they put up their doubts and you
this community of practice is really a
good thing and
and of course with kind of umass
certification there which has
more value i think i've seen all the
students
who have and as i see them some of them
here uh been commander sadhana and all i
have interacted with them in the classes
and you know and most of them have been
amazing because they've been very sharp
they've been very responsive and they've
been very responsible on top of that so
that shows that you know the real uh the
passion for learning uh never stops as
ram said i second that and special
regards to raam mark and tracy for that
whatever words they said
it's absolutely an inspirational journey
for me so i believe that as a trainer
unless we are inspired we can't transfer
the inspiration to the learners so i
stay inspired i learn every day
because i need to practice my words so
that is what i'm sure my learners would
agree with me and i what i do is i try
to give them
the kind of
insights and i combine
certain insights of life into
the concepts so
two things happen there one
it remains in their mind forever and you
know it inspires them so it doesn't it's
not that
the dull
way of just going through the concepts
because they're all at the end of the
day they're
spending their valuable weekend hours
with us so i take it upon myself as my
prime responsibility to ensure that i
make it interesting and i don't just
deliver lectures i deliver experience
and that's what uh umass and simply
learn resonates with thank you having
said that for giving me this wonderful
opportunity i am so so happy that so
many people uh see them graduate out of
here and the first convocation is
amazing and you guys are doing a
fantastic job the entire team backhand
and front end of simply learn and the
umass
keep it going i think we have got so
much to achieve there are so many out
people out there in the world
waiting to get themselves upskilled
all the best thank you
thank you
have anita
share her stories with us
hello everyone hi paris
can you hear me just a quick mic check
yeah yeah we can hear you
okay okay that's good i would love to be
on camera but most of my students know
that i was recovering uh from kovit but
let's not talk about it i just went
through little physical damage but
nothing could do to my voice yeah so
sorry about that otherwise i would love
to be on camera
hey guys i'm so excited
today to see each one of you and i see
most of my students here i'm so so happy
and i can't um
uh agree more to what our trainer
sridhar said and it's exactly like what
i wanted to say yes first of all i would
like to
uh thank uh simply learn a big uh thank
you to simply learn not only uh for
giving me this opportunity as a trainer
but but as a learner because being a
trainer you also learn isn't it and
learning is a journey and when you train
you are all when you teach you are half
learning and i must say that the content
and the structure is so very well
thought and the kind of support we get
the students
know
oh you know they have taken some names
and thank you thank you a few of my
students who have taken my name as well
thank you but i must say that you know
people who
um
make us so capable to deliver this
training are also our content uh
developers our program managers they not
only develop it and send it to us but
they also have a session with us they
also have meetings with us they also
tell us that you know this would be
great learning experience for people you
know this is how you should put yourself
in the shoes so thank you so much uh
simply learn
and
and uh thank you um
i would like to thank the students as
well
now first of all
my uh lean six sigma students
uh everybody knows i started my
uh
my journey with six sigma in 2006 though
i come over like 20 or more more than 20
years of experience but lean six sigma
is what what has helped me what has
taken my career to the next level
and uh this is one of the
best ways to upskill yourself reskill
yourself in a way you could open up for
new opportunities and this is a bundle
isn't it this pg program is a bundle so
you get so many opportunities so many
certifications with you so this is a
type of certification that allows you to
change your direction in your career and
at the same time also increase your
value in the market and end of the day
it is all about value isn't it so i'm
really very happy uh that i could
contribute here and it is only 20
contribution of the trainers but 80
percent is from students because it's
not easy to just give up your weekends
and be here listen to somebody so boring
and uh you know listen to the concept
and stuff and that too virtual not even
not even activity or something because
after covered but during the pandemic we
have completely moved to virtua
so a few of the many reasons i love
about the certification is
uh it is industry neutral it is
department neutral and you can apply
these tools and techniques in any
business unit or function so whether
you're from pharmaceutical industry
you're a manufacturer you're a doctor
you're an engineer doesn't matter you
have these certifications and you you
have an added value in the market
and the reason why companies will love
you now is because you will be able to
solve their complex problems and
increase the bottom line and end of the
day it is all bottom line isn't it who
doesn't who doesn't like bottom line
right it's end of it it's all money now
people say we can't buy happiness uh
with money but most of it most of the
things that give us happiness is with
money isn't it so when you increase the
bottom line for your company your
company loves you and then we get
rewarded with our increment and
promotion and growth opportunity wow
exciting isn't it yeah so you can
improve your bottom line not only uh by
improving the revenue but also reducing
the midline that is fast and lean and
all these certifications will help you
identify the waste in the system
eliminated well done well done now few
um
avenues that decertification and this
program will help you would be you could
be
of course you could be awarded with your
promotion and increment now along with
that you can also be a consultant you
can be a project manager manager you
could be a six sigma consultant you
could be a freelance lean expert you
could author a book now you could be
a reviewer for authors who write books
on program management and lead six sigma
uh agile and other program you could be
a lecturer you could be a trainer isn't
it
so go ahead connect with like-minded
people on linkedin follow simply learn
as well because simply learn has a very
very rich network of people where you
could you could just mention that you
are
a pmp now you're a lean expert now
connect with these experts and company
and get more business so congratulations
and best wishes for your future
individuals and keep the momentum going
thank you thank you very much
many thanks anita uh we also have
bernard here let's have one in it share
our story
hey everyone it is my great honor to be
speaking with you this evening
when i started my journey with simply
learn i had no idea what to expect
i had never taught classes in this
structure in this space only hosted
workshops and that was a mere four years
ago
and now today i am able to make an
impact not on just students in the us
but all over the world so it's
definitely a great honor
and the content and the things that we
pour out for you guys
is a part of our passion and a part of
what we do
and you're finally here
you may not have known where the road
was going to take you
but i can assure you just like it was
not mine it is not your final
destination
your commitment your effort and you
making this important milestone is proof
that you possess
the qualities that it take to stand out
to be among the best
every assessment
every project
every discussion that you contributed to
has brought you to great recognition
but learning like many others that have
spoken before me has said is lifelong
and for every course that you commit to
you add just a little bit more character
and value to your experience
and i sincerely apo applaud your
accomplishments
as you're the reasons why the
instructors like myself are passionate
about what we do
if i can impart one thing it would be to
always challenge yourself
to new and greater personal heights
and a quote that i always sign my
classes off with when we are in our last
few sessions
is you don't have to be the first as
something great
you just have to be the best at
achieving something great i wish you all
the best in your endeavors have a
wonderful day
and a great future ahead
thank you thank you bernadette as i'm
energized
again listening to your stories uh
now we would also like to thank
our master class instructors for
facilitating us with different
interesting topics every month
now moving on to our core team at simply
learn
we have our learner success managers
you know here's the team who is
responsible for the sessions and the
tickets that you post many would have
interacted
many of you would have interacted with
them directly
let's let's move on
this is this is our leadership team
this is uh this is our faculty and
alignment team they're responsible for
hand-picking and getting us the best
trainers
thanks
this is our content team responsible for
all the content and curriculum that we
see in terms of live virtual class as
well as
self learning videos
and we have our product team
the brains behind curating the program
and structuring it
they've been the bridge between simply
learn and umass and they've been the
drivers of the program let's let's take
a moment to thank and applaud
uh them for their efforts thank you
thank you so much team
um
i'm sure uh you know right now all of
you are in a very happy state of
mind
and and you know happiness is only real
when it is shared
this is a quote from the movie into the
wild so it will be great if you share
with the world your achievements you
have all the social media platforms feel
free to
share your achievements with the with
the wider world
um
we wish each and every graduate all the
very best for the future
and we believe being aspirational is the
first
part of being successful
many of you will excel in different
streams of your career once again it's a
heartfelt
gratitude from us
for you choosing safety learn to be your
partner to skill up
we want to leave you with one thought
today you are now
all of you are now
ambassadors of the umass simply learn pg
programs
people will now follow your footsteps
and you will their guiding light
to success
uh we would request you to be active in
our communities and post feel free to
post some interesting topics
uh and also keep us posted
about
your success stories tag us
so we can celebrate as well and and we
can also set the path right for the
future learners and the future leaders
thank you uh all for making this
event a successful one
and one last time
you know it will be it would be great if
you could share your views about today's
event in the survey link
pasted in the chat box
so
good night good day
good evening
and
good luck everyone
congratulations everyone
all the best all the best thank you
congratulations
bye thank you congratulations to all of
you
you